Lesson 10 no hajime no, saishŘ no kai, kanji
desu.
The first kanji character in lesson 10.
Kono kanji desu keredo mo, imi wa ÔvisitŐ
to iu imi desu.
Chotto component wo mite mimashŘ.
Mazu, kono hidarigawa no left part component
kore wa Ôa languageŐ or Ôsay wordsŐ
something to do with language or saying.
Tatoeba, Ôhanasu,Ő Ôto speakŐ
Sore kara ÔNihongoŐ kore wa ÔlanguageŐ
to iu imi ga arimasu yo ne.
Sore kara migigawa kono kanji desu keredo
mo kore wa ÔdirectionŐ no imi ga arimasu.
Tatoeba, Ôkochira no hŘ,Ő Ôthis wayŐ,
sore kara ÔhŘkŘ,Ő ÔdirectionŐ to
iu imi desu.
So someone is going toward your direction
to say something someone is going to visit
to iu imi desu.
De, yomikata nan desu keredo mo, on reading
de ÔhŘŐ
Tatoeba, ÔhŘmon suruŐ
ÔKyŘto wo hŘmon suru.Ő
Ôtanaka-san no uchi wo hŘmon suruŐ kore
mo daijŘbu desu.
Ônani nani wo hŘmon suruŐ kore de ÔvisitŐ
Sore kara kun reading de Ôtazuneru, otozureruŐ
konna yomikata ga arimasu.
Tatoeba, Ôtazuneru,Ő Ôto visitŐ nan
desu keredo mo
Kore wa transitive verb desu.
Desu kara, tatoeba, ÔKyŘto wo tazuneta.Ő
HŘmon suru to onaji imi nan desu keredo mo
kochira no hou ga mŘ sukoshi conversational
desu.
ÔKyŘto wo tazuneta.Ő
Sore kara Ôtanaka-san wo tazunetaŐ kore
daijŘbu desu.
Sore kara ÔotozureruŐ kore wa intransitive,
transitive, both possible desu.
Tatoeba, Ômukashi no tomodachi wo otozuretaŐ
Ôvisited my old friend.Ő
Kono toki wa transitive usage.
So you need an wo particle here.
But Ômukashi no tomodachi ga otozuretaŐ
kore wa Ômy old friend visited me.Ő
So here, subject marker ÔgaŐ needs to
appear.
So be careful, the usage of this particle
actually determines whether it is transitive
or intransitive.
Tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji desu keredo mo, imi wa Ôscene
sore de component nan desu keredo mo, kono
top part, kore wa Nihon no ni.
The sun, desu yo ne.
Sore kara, bottom part.
Kore wa KyŘto no kyŘ.
So it means Őthe capitalŐ to iu imi desu.
You can imagine the sun is rising behind KyŘto
or behind the capital.
What a beautiful scene to iu imi desu.
Yomikata nan desu keredo mo, on reading Ôk•Ő
desu.
Tatoeba Ôfđk•Ő Ôscene, sceneryŐ
Sore kara Ôyak•,Ő kore wa Ôyoru no,Ő
Ônight sceneŐ
Sore kara Ôk•kiŐ kore wa desu ne, Ôbusiness
or economic conditionsŐ to iu imi desu.
Ato, chotto tokubetsu na yomikata nan desu
keredo mo, kore de ÔkeshikiŐ to yomimasu.
ÔkeshikiŐ to iu no wa Ôscene, sceneryŐ
to iu imi desu.
Hai, tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji desu keredo mo, imi wa ÔdistrictŐ
sore kara ÔwardŐ to iu imi ga arimasu.
De, story desu keredo mo, you can imagine
a box or some area, and then you kind of you
know, separate it so that you can get a district.
De, kono kanji district no imi desu.
De, yomikata nan desu keredo mo, on reading
de ÔkuŐ to iu no ga arimasu.
Tatoeba kore ÔchikuŐ ÔdistrictŐ
Sore kara desu ne, kono ÔwardŐ to iu no
de Tokyo has 23 wards, and then so each ward
you can use this character to indicate a ward.
So ÔShinjuku kuŐ kore wa ÔShinjuku wardŐ
Sore kara ÔNerima kuŐ
This kanji can be used as a suffix to indicate
this ward.
Sore kara Ôkubetsu suruŐ kore, Ôto distinguishŐ
to iu imi desu.
Tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji desu keredo mo, imi wa ÔdangerousŐ
to iu imi desu.
De, component nan desu keredo mo, you can
imagine someoneŐs mouth so someone is talking,
mouth is open, and this part nan desu keredo
mo, this part actually means Ôbad luckŐ
So someone who has bad luck is talking to
you.
So itŐs dangerous to iu imi desu.
De, yomikata nan desu keredo mo, on reading
de ÔkiŐ
Tatoeba, ÔkikenŐ ÔdangerousŐ
Ato desu ne, kun reading de ÔabunaiŐ to
iu yomikata ga arimasu.
ÔabunaiŐ to iu toki wa Ôwatch outŐ
no imi desu.
Mochiron adjective toshite desu ne, Ôkono
chiku wa abunaiŐ tatoeba, Ôthis area is
dangerous.Ő
Konna tsukaikata mo shimasu.
Tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji desu keredo mo, imi wa ÔdangerŐ
or ÔsteepŐ to iu imi ga arimasu.
Kono component, radical nan desu keredo mo,
this radical refers to like, hill, or high
mountain to iu imi ga arimasu.
ItŐs actually originally coming from this
shape of mountains.
Sore kara kono kanji nan desu keredo mo, you
know this ÔshikenŐ or ÔjikkenŐ this
part so this kind of you know kanji is associated
with the meaning of examination.
So a story goes like this, when you try to
climb a steep mountain or a hill, you need
to examine it.
To iu no de steep, sore kara dangerous.
Sonna imi ga arimasu.
Yomikata nan desu keredo mo, on reading de
Ôkiken,Ő saki benkyŘshimashita kedo kore,
Ôkiken,Ő Ôdanger, dangerous, double
dangerŐ nan desu keredo mo, kore Ôkiken
na,Ő ma, ÔdangerousŐ
Ôkoko wa kiken na chiku desuŐ so Ôthis
is a dangerous areaŐ
Sore kara Ôkiken na koto wa shinai de kudasaiŐ
ÔdonŐt do anything dangerousŐ
Sore kara ÔhokenŐ to iu no, kore wa, kono
ÔhoŐ tte iu no wa Ôto protectŐ to
iu imi ga arimasu.
So to protect you from danger thing, to iu
no de, ÔinsuranceŐ to iu imi ga arimasu.
Ato, kun reading nan desu keredo mo, kun reading
no toki wa desu ne, ÔsteepŐ no imi ga
arimasu.
Kore, tatoeba, Ôkewashii,Ő Ôsteep.Ő
Ôkewashii yama,Ő Ôsteep mountainŐ
to iu tsukaikata ga arimasu.
Hai. tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji desu keredo mo, imi wa ÔserviceŐ
sore kara ÔroleŐ no imi ga arimasu.
Component nan desu keredo mo, so this radical
means ÔgoŐ we pronounce ÔikuŐ
Now the right-hand side this part you can
imagine a soldier with a big helmet.
So soldiers go to a battle in the service
of their lord.
Sonna imi de daijŘbu desu.
Yomikata nan desu keredo mo, onreading ÔyakuŐ
Tatoeba Ôkonna yaku wo shite mitaiŐ ÔIŐd
like to try this type of roleŐ
Sore kara ÔyakuninŐ kore wa Ôgovernment
officialŐ
Sore kara ÔyakushoŐ Ôpublic officeŐ
Sore kara ÔyakushaŐ kore wa ÔactorŐ
or ÔactressŐ no imi desu.
Sore kara adjective nan desu, mitai nan desu
kedo mo, Ôyaku ni tatsuŐ this is in Japanese
itŐs a verb.
So Ôyaku ni tatsuŐ Ôyaku ni tachimasuŐ
Tatoeba, Ôkono video wa kanji no benkyŘ
ni yaku dachimasuŐ Ôthis video is useful
for kanji study.Ő
Particle kiwotsukete kudasai.
Hai, tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji desu keredo mo, ironna imi ga arun
desu keredo mo, Ôministry, save, reflect
on,Ő sore kara ÔomitŐ to iu imi, iroiro
na imi ga arimasu.
De, you can imagine the story this part, ÔsmallŐ
ÔsukoshiŐ to iu imi desu ne.
Sore kara this is Ôeye.Ő
So with a small eye you might omit something
to iu imi nan desu ga.
Yomikata.
On reading de ÔshŘŐ or Ôs•Ő to iu
no ga arimasu.
Kono lesson 10 de tsukawareru, tsukaikata,
ÔshŘ eneŐ Ôeconomical use of energyŐ
Sore kara kono Ônani nani shŘŐ to iu
no de as a suffix it indicates Ôministry
of.Ő
Tatoeba, ÔgaimushŘŐ Ôministry of foreign
affairsŐ konna tsukaikata wo shimasu.
Sore kara Ôhans• suru,Ő Ôto reflect
onŐ
Sore kara Ôkis• suruŐ kore wa Ôto go
home townŐ uchi no bai ni tatoeba just regular
home no toki ni wa Ôuchi ni kaeru.Ő
Kis• suru tte iu no wa specifically for go
back to your hometown no imi ga arimasu.
Ato, kun reading de ÔhabukuŐ to iu yomikata
wo shimasu.
ÔTo omitŐ no imi desu.
Tatoeba, Ôkono bubun wa habuite kudasaiŐ
Ôkono bubun wo habuite kudasaiŐ daijŘbu
desu.
So Ôplease omit this part to iu imi desu.
Hai, tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji desu keredo mo, imi wa ÔcoldŐ
no imi desu.
Component nan desu keredo mo, kono radical,
kore wa ÔiceŐ to iu imi ga arimasu.
Kiwotsukete kudasai.
Kore wa ÔwaterŐ demo kore to wa chigaimasu.
Futatsu, nihon, just two lines.
Sore kara kochira no component, this part
indicates actually Ôorder
So tatoeba, R•wa, this is the name of the
Japanese current era, R•wa.
So the order of peace to iu imi ga arun desu
keredo mo,
Usually orders are not warm, ice cold to iu
no de, cold desu.
De, yomikata nan desu keredo mo,
Ôr•Ő to iu no ga arimasu.
Tatoeba Ôr•suiŐ kore wa Ôtotemo tsumetaiŐ
Ôcold waterŐ
Sore kara Ôr•tŘŐ Ôto freezeŐ
Ôr•sŘkŘŐ ÔrefrigeratorŐ
Sore kara Ôr•bŘŐ kono ÔbŘŐ tte
iu no wa ÔheyaŐ to iu, ÔroomŐ to iu
imi ga arimasu.
So Ôair conditioningŐ
Sore kara kun reading nan desu keredo mo,
tatoeba ÔhiyasuŐ Ônani nani wo hiyasuŐ
kore wa transitive verb desu.
Tatoeba, Ôbeer wo hiyashite kudasaiŐ
Sore kara intransitive verb no toki tatoeba,
Ôbeer ga hieteimasuŐ kiwotsukete kudasai.
Ôhiyasu, hieruŐ kore wa transitive intransitive
verb pair.
Sore kara adjective ÔtsumetaiŐ
Tatoeba, Ôkono beer ga tsumetai desuŐ
Ôthis beer is coldŐ kŘ iu yomikata mo
shimasu.
Tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji, imi wa ÔgeneralŐ sore kara
ÔofficerŐ to iu imi ga arimasu.
I donŐt have any interesting story associated
with this kanji so IŐm going to just jump
onto this reading part.
On reading de ÔshŘŐ to yomimasu.
Ichiban yoku tsukawareru no wa ÔshŘraiŐ
Ôin the futureŐ
ÔshŘrai, nani ni naritai desu ka?Ő
Sore kara ÔshŘgunŐ to iu mo, kono shŘ
wo tsukaimasu.
Hai, tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji desu keredo mo, imi wa ÔemotionŐ
sore kara Ôactual conditionsŐ to iu imi
ga arimasu.
Component nan desu keredo mo, so this radical
is actually associated with the meaning of
Ôheart, mind, feelings.Ő
ItŐs actually coming from the shape of oneŐs
heart.
Sore kara, migigawa, right-hand side, this,
actually this character itself means ÔaoiŐ
blue, nan desu keredo mo, so the color of
blue is associated with the meaning of immature
or young.
So the young heart has lots of emotions so
the whole kanji means emotion.
De, yomikata nan desu keredo mo, on reading
de ÔjŘŐ
Tatoeba, ÔjŘhŘŐ kore wa, ma, ÔinformationŐ
kore dakara Ôactual conditionŐ desu yo ne.
The report of the actual condition, ma, information
to iu imi desu.
Ato desu ne, kore ÔkanjŘŐ kore wa ÔemotionŐ
ÔaijŘŐ kono ÔaiŐ to iu no wa ÔloveŐ
no imi ga arimasu.
So ÔaijŘŐ to iu no wa Ôlove feelingŐ
nan desu keredo, ma, Ôromantic feelingŐ
ÔloveŐ to iu imi desu.
ÔyđjŘ,Őkono ÔyđŐ to iu no wa Ôtomodachi,Ő
ÔfriendŐ desu.
So Ôfriendship.Ő
ÔdŘjŘŐ kore wa ÔsympathyŐ no imi
desu.
Ato, kun reading de ÔnasaŐ to yomimasu.
Tatoeba, Ônasake ga aru,Ő Ôsympathy,
compassionŐ ga aru to iu imi desu.
Sore kara ÔnasakenaiŐ kore Ômiserable,
shamefulŐ to iu adjective, konna tsukaikata
ga arimasu.
Hai, tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji desu keredo mo, imi ga iroiro arimasu.
Ôinform, require, news, report, rewardŐ
De, component nan desu keredo mo, so the left-hand
side kore wa ÔhappinessŐ to iu, by itself
itŐs happiness.
Sore kara the right-hand side you can imagine
oneŐs hands and then some envelope.
So thereŐs an envelope in your hands that
make you happy.
This envelope must be some sort of reward
or good report.
De, reading nan desu keredo mo, on reading
de ÔhŘŐ
ÔjŘhŘŐ ÔinformationŐ
Sore kara ÔhŘkokuŐ Ôto reportŐ ÔhŘkoku
shite kudasaiŐ
Sore kara ÔtenkiyohŘŐ Ôweather forecastŐ
Sore kara ÔsokuhŘŐ kono ÔsokuŐ tte
iu no wa ÔhayaiŐ hŘkoku, report tte iu
no de, ma, Ôurgent reportŐ ari wa ÔnewsflashŐ
sonna imi ga arimasu.
Ato, kun reading de ÔmukuiruŐ
Amari tsukaimasen keredo mo, tatoeba, ÔTanaka-san
wo mukuiŐ ÔI rewarded Tanaka-sanŐ sonna
tsukaikata mo arimasu.
Hai, tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji desu keredo mo, imi wa ÔaloneŐ
to ka, kono kanji wa toki doki Doitsu, Germany
wo imi shimasu.
De, component nan desu keredo mo, kono radical
this radical is actually based on the shape
of a beast or animal to iu imi desu.
Kono radical wa itŐs associated with beast.
Sore kara, kono migigawa, this part by itself
is ÔmushiŐ ÔinsectŐ so you can imagine
a story like thereŐs only, only one insect
on this animal.
So itŐs alone.
De, reading nan desu keredo mo, ÔdokuŐ
to iu yomikata desu.
Tatoeba, Ôdokuritsu, dokuritsu suruŐ
Ôdokuritsu suruŐ tte iu no de Ôto become
independentŐ
Sore kara ÔdokushinŐ kore wa ÔsingleŐ
talking about marriage status.
Sore kara ÔdokugakuŐ kore wa Ôhitori
de benkyŘ suruŐ to iu no de Ôself studyŐ
Sore kara ÔkodokuŐ to iu no de, na adjective
nan desu kedo, ÔlonelyŐ
Ôano hito wa kodoku na hito desuŐ Ôhe
is, or that person is a lonely person.Ő
Konna tsukaikata ga arimasu.
Sore kara saki iimashita keredo mo, kŘ itta,
hitotsu no kanji, one kanji character stands
for a particular country.
Tatoeba, kore wa America, sore kara niban
me, kore wa France sore kara kono kanji, this
character stands for Germany.
Kun reading desu keredo mo, Ôhitori.Ő
Tatoeba, ÔhitoriŐ ÔaloneŐ
Ôhitori monoŐ kore mo ÔsingleŐ to
iu imi desu.
Ma, in terms of marriage ÔhitorimonoŐ
ÔIŐm singleŐ Ôhitorimono desuŐ to iu.
Dokushin to onaji imi desu.
Kono kanji desu, kono kanji desu keredo mo,
imi wa ÔbodyŐ to ka ÔoneselfŐ no imi
ga arimasu.
I donŐt have a particular story about this
character, but you can kind of imagine a human
body that entire body and then associated
with this character.
De, yomikata reading kore wa Ôshin.Ő
Tatoeba, ÔdokushinŐ together with the
previous kanji character, kore ÔaloneŐ
and ÔbodyŐ
Ôalone bodyŐ kore ÔsingleŐ talking
about marriage status.
Sore kara ÔshinchŘŐ kore wa, kono kanji
wa ÔlengthŐ so Ôlength of the bodyŐ
Ôheight.Ő
ÔshintaiŐ kore wa Ôbody bodyŐ nan
desu keredo mo, simply ÔbodyŐ no imi desu.
Sore kara ÔshusshinŐ kore wa Ôthe place
where your body is coming fromŐ tte iu no
de, ma, ÔhometownŐ Ôshusshin, goshusshin
wa doko desu kaŐ to iu imi desu.
Ato, kun reading, kore ÔmiŐ to iu imi
desu keredo mo, jitsu wa ÔsashimiŐ kono
kanji mi wo tsukaimasu.
Sore kara ÔmijikanaŐ nan desu keredo mo,
Ôclose to your bodyŐ nan desu keredo mo,
this is more talking about psychologically,
emotionally close, familiar sore kara, tatoeba,
Ômijikana hitoŐ close friends to ka close
family mijikana hito to ittara tatoeba kazoku
to ka close friends no imi ga arimasu.
Mijikana hito.
Hai.
Hai. Tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji desu keredo mo, imi wa ÔdistantŐ
sore kara ÔfarŐ no imi ga arimasu.
De, component nan desu keredo mo, this radical
is always associated with leg.
Sore kara kono part kono part desu keredo
mo, this is exactly the same as this inside,
kore, ÔkŘenŐ ÔparkŐ desu keredo mo,
so this part is the same as this and the inside
part.
De, leg and en sore de distant.
I donŐt have a particularly good story about
this but kono combination wa this combination
distant, far, de, on reading desu ga, Ôen.Ő
Tatoeba, ÔensokuŐ kore Ôfield tripŐ
nan desu keredo mo, the second character here
is ÔlegŐ and then so leg with leg, go
distantly, so Ôfield trip.Ő
Sore kara Ô•Ően,Ő kore wa Ô•Ő
the first character indicate ÔforeverŐ
no imi desu.
So forever distant, far, eternity.
Sore kara, kun reading nan desu keredo mo,
kore wa ÔtŘiŐ desu yo ne, ÔtŘi,Ő
kiwotsukete kudasai kore kochira ga ÔchikaiŐ
opposite word itŐs ÔchikaiŐ Ôclose.Ő
Hai.
De wa, tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji desu keredo mo, imi wa Ôto line
up,Ő ÔordinaryŐ to iu imi desu.
Kore wa, this kanji you can kind of associate
it with that image two people standing side
by side, line up.
De, yomikata nan desu keredo mo, kun reading
kore de ÔnaraberuŐ transitive intransitive
pair ga arimasu.
Transitive de Ônaraberu.Ő
Intransitive de Ônarabu.Ő
Transitive case, tatoeba, Ôkono hon wo narabete
kudasaiŐ Ôline up these booksŐ
Sore kara, ÔnarabuŐ intransitive no toki
wa Ôhito gaŐ particle wo kiwotsukete kudasai,
Ôhito ga narandeimasu.Ő
Ôpeople are lining up.Ő
Ato, extra kind of information nan desu keredo
mo, on reading de Ôh•retsu.Ő
Kono ÔretsuŐ tte iu no wa ÔlineŐ no
imi ga arimasu.
Sore de Ôh•retsuŐ kore de ÔparallelŐ
to iu adjective desu.
So, tatoeba, Ôkono futatsu no sen wa,Ő
Ôthese two lines are parallel.Ő
Ôh•betsu desu.Ő
Konna tsukaikata mo arimasu.